ahora vamos de salud en directo américa
de francés 24 con más romeros a la mar
empezamos esta nueva semana y vamos a
iniciar con este nuevo espacio de salud
un nuevo espacio después de toda la
guerra no marc para hablar de los
efectos del cob y 19 sobre nuestro
cerebro
pues yo agua meter es la cucharada
también y yo me he sentido después del
cohete y si me ve con un poco más
disperso he cambiado algunos nombres
como la memoria que yo era buena memoria
como no estaba muy bien cuáles son los
hallazgos más recientes puedo tener algo
indicios del cohete cerebro todavía
definitivamente sí porque no eres el
único que ha reportado este tipo de
síntomas a mí incluso también me sucedió
unos síntomas que se ven pocos meses
después de la infección pero en este
estudio concreto del que vamos a hablar
hoy no te va a responder esas preguntas
sobre todo por un tema de edad ahora
ahora lo repasamos da más profundidad es
un estudio que se publicó hace unas
semanas pero que recuperamos ahora en la
revista han hecho por parte de la
universidad de oxford y vemos que los
principales hallazgos son que el tamaño
del cerebro de las personas afectadas
por el cómic 19 se redujo entre un 0,2
por ciento y 12 por ciento más que las
personas que no habían tenido una
infección por el virus del cob y 19
decimos más porque a partir de cierta
edad el cerebro en sí ya va reduciéndose
de manera anual y también de manera
natural también se descubrió que las
áreas más afectadas son esas que están
relacionadas con el olor pero también
con la memoria y que las personas que
tuvieron cobit tuvieron algo más de
dificultad a la hora de realizar tareas
mentales complejas por aquí podéis lo
que me comentabas tú aunque la
diferencia fue pequeña y sobre todo se
vio en las franjas más elevadas de edad
entonces esos son los ha sido marc en
los casos graves de la enfermedad o
también en los casos leves pues una de
las cosas más interesantes de este
estudio es que la gran mayoría de los
casos que se estudiaron que fueron unos
800 casos de los cuales la mitad habían
pasado por el cómic 19 fueron casos
leves sólo el 15 sólo 15 casos habían
requerido hospitalización en esta
revista han hecho también pues
publicaron uno de los gráficos que
estamos viendo en este momento donde la
línea azul son los casos del control del
grupo de control que se llama es decir
de las personas que no pasaron por la
infección y la línea las personas que sí
se enfermaron de 19 más que la
diferencia en lo que llamamos el grosor
del córtex que es una parte del cerebro
de la que ahora hablaremos se profundiza
mucho con la edad del estudio se hizo a
partir de los 50 años pero vemos que esa
diferencia se hace mucho más pronunciada
a partir de los 78 es interesante porque
se corresponde de hecho con algo que
vieron en el estudio y es que como
decíamos de esa diferencia a la hora de
realizar tareas pues también se
profundizaba a la hora pues con la edad
no a medida que la gente era más mayor y
que sabemos de estas áreas del cerebro
más afectadas por el coi 19 pues sabemos
que los autores del estudio lo han
relacionado sobre todo con el sentido
del olfato con los circuitos
neurológicos del sentido del olfato hay
dos partes particularmente de las que
podemos hablar que se han visto
afectadas también la vemos en esta
imagen que se publicó en la revista una
es el córtex orbitofrontal es la parte
que está justo encima de nuestros ojos y
otras del giro parahipocampo que se
encuentra como en el medio del cerebro
en la parte de la corteza puede estar
parte está relacionada con el
pensamiento racional
toma de decisiones y el giro
parahipocámpico con funciones de memoria
a largo plazo y forma parte del sistema
límbico que es el que regula las
emociones el comportamiento entonces
como vemos el no hay una parte del
cerebro que cumpla una sola función sino
que todas tienen varias cosas entonces
pues hay esta relación entre el sentido
del olfato pero entre estas otras
funciones que falta ver exactamente cómo
se relaciona y que podría tener el coach
19 con esto marc y todos sabemos
precisamente que es una enfermedad
respiratoria que nos afecta nuestro fuma
necesito pero entonces ahora yo le
pregunto qué tiene que ver con nuestro
cerebro pues es una de las grandes
preguntas que deja el estudio se sabe
algunas cosas más y de hecho pudimos
preguntarle al doctor carlos pérez uno
de los asesores científicos de france 24
que nos podía comentar el al respecto
escuchemos lo
la afectación del cerebro por el coi no
es exclusiva de este virus hay varios
virus que afectan el cerebro sin embargo
la característica que hacen el código es
que tiene varios daños relacionados uno
por el daño directo que se produce
durante la fase inflamatoria de esta
enfermedad sobre todo en personas que
son muy sintomáticos y que tiene una
enfermedad severa y otro por
alteraciones en la oxigenación y por
alteraciones en la circulación por
fenómenos trombóticos que se ha
relacionado con la enfermedad
estamos hablando entonces de trombosis
de inflamaciones pero lo interesante es
que eso ocurre sobre todo con casos del
coi 19 de cuadros de enfermedad grave
mientras que en este caso como veíamos
muchos de los síntomas habían sido leves
otra de las hipótesis que se manejan es
que puede ser que el hecho de quedarse
sin olor a raíz de la enfermedad de se
entrene estos circuitos neurológicos del
sentido del olfato y eso termine dañando
estas regiones del cerebro sin embargo
pues todavía no se sabe con certeza
conclusiones que nos deja el estudio y
también por supuesto las interrogantes
así es para cerrar un poco esta parte
indudable que este estudio es muy
valioso porque todo el mundo sabe que
algo sucede ahí alguna cosa está pasando
pero pues no habíamos visto poderlo ver
en imágenes no se imaginaba también eso
por algunos síntomas que decías como la
desconcentración esa niebla mental
incluso síntomas como depresión o
ansiedad que han afectado después de los
contagios entonces eso empieza a arrojar
luz en esta relación entre pues la mente
el cerebro y el commit 19 pero por
ejemplo cosas que todavía no se saben si
los cambios son permanentes si se van a
poder solucionar o no qué pasa con la
edad claramente es un factor de riesgo
pero pues les estudio a partir de 50
años entonces no sabemos qué puede pasar
con los contagios más jóvenes y también
pues es muy importante decir que este
estudio todavía no ha terminado todavía
se van a investigar más casos esperamos
también que eso nos dé más conclusiones
bueno mar vamos a ver qué pasa entonces
y por supuesto esperemos que sea algo
pasajero yo creo que ya igual como que
me serio de esta red comprando la
normalidad esperemos que así esperemos
que al mar muchísimas gracias como
siempre un gusto conversar contigo
acerca de los temas de salud pasamos a
saludar a nuestra